It's Teacher Appreciation week.
Are there any teachers you would like to apologize to?
Sure.
My 5th grade teacher.
Her name was Miss Glasser.
I gave her the nickname "Gassy Goo," and it stuck with her the whole year.
I apologize to my kindergarten teacher for kicking her every day.
Almost every day.
I would come in and kick her for no reason.
And after that, in first grade, my first grade teacher, I would hit her with a rubber band and paper.
So, things got worse.
Yeah.
There was a teacher at Tesoro High School in Orange County...
...who had very, very big curly hair, and when she turned around to write on the board,...
...we would roll up little pieces  of paper and see how many we could stick in her hair....
...without her knowing.